so thomas here is going to get interview
is interviewing steve
thomas
all right so steve yes it's it's a
pleasure for me to interview you
and uh my friend yeah we as link
students
usually ask oca to face with link
when we
meet your little white coated character
right radio yes
and then we get started at link and we
see your face in the english related
videos right but uh
for me
personally i don't really know much
about your life before right we heard
that you were kind of in business and
you were working as a diplomat
but would you talk a little bit more
about this because i'm really interested
okay well if we're talking about my
professional career
i started with the canadian government
diplomatic trade service so in other
words this is sort of a diplomatic corps
that works in embassies overseas to help
canadian business people to gather
economic intelligence on these countries
you know opportunities
positions that the host country might be
taking in some international economic
conference so that was kind of
that's the nature of the job and my
first assignment was to go to hong kong
to study chinese because canada was
getting ready in 1968 to recognize the
people's republic of china
all right so that's where my kind of
language thing all started
and so i studied chinese in hong kong
and thereafter i
went to tokyo
and i was at the embassy in tokyo for
four months for four years working in
different sectors and and towards the
end of that i was in the forest product
sector as a result of that i was hired
by a major canadian exporter to set up
their office in tokyo
all right so then i did that
worked with them for quite a while and
then i was hired by their largest
competitor to do the same for the
competitors so i started the tokyo
office for two of the major canadian
lumber exporting companies and then in
1987 i set up my own company
where we tried to develop sort of call
them niche products and you're familiar
with that word
these products products that let's say
the big industry didn't want to produce
and i had my ideas on how we could
actually manufacture those products to
japanese requirements and so that was
the beginning of kp wood
so i did that and that company still
exists i'm not so active in it anymore
but i spent a good you know whatever it
was 25 years
in the lumber business traveling largely
to japan which i really enjoyed because
japan has a wonderful wood culture
which is something that was a wonderful
experience for me
um and then along the way i i learned
other languages
i got interested in languages i think
once you know that you can learn
languages you learn one and a second and
a third then you get kind of motivated
and and then and of course my son mark
who
is getting there's a long story here but
my wife and i both speak languages we
wanted our kids to speak languages of
course whatever parents want the kids
resist right that's the nature of things
uh however he
ended up playing professional hockey in
europe he was in italy in austria and
switzerland and then in japan and he
suddenly realized that actually it's
useful to speak other languages so he
now speaks a number of languages and we
started linked then about 10 years ago
twitch i'm sure every teacher feels this
if they just go into all their students
and just turn the switch that's all they
need to do so he turned my switch and
then i just pursued french and that was
a major event in my life because i then
got interested in they had this sort of
new wave you know nouvelle vag movies in
those days in french and there were so
many aspects of french culture that
interested me and then i ended up going
to france for three years where i did my
university training so that was the one
thing the second thing was being
assigned to hong kong to learn chinese
because i mean
coming from a western culture you know
to discover chinese culture like it was
unbelievably uh exotic i was in the
fortunate position that that the
government
um paid for me to study so i was earning
my salary and just studying every day
which is the only time i've ever been in
that situation that's great that's a
good good one yes so like seven hours a
day i was studying chinese
and so that was the the
second major thing by then you know when
i went to japan i didn't have to
basically go to school i just i knew
then that you have to as i always say
listen and read a lot so i just listen
read listen read and eventually my
japanese develop and i guess the third
thing was this whole link thing which
started
because we'd hired a guy from china
who
an immigrant to vancouver had all his
money stolen at the airport by some
local gangs or something because they
know that chinese come with
all their life savings you know in a bag
around their neck kind of thing
largely chinese dance and uh so we felt
sorry for this guy who said we'll hire
him
and uh if he's good he helps us if he's
not
any if he can't function well at least
we gave him a couple of months right so
in the end it didn't work out that well
largely because of his english he had
this high score in toeic because they
all learn how to you know toeic or yeah
they all know how to write the exam but
they still can't speak the language
right so we started developing link
basically for him and then we thought
this is kind of good and then we tried
to in
interest the the immigration department
but they were there
it's a whole bureaucratic mess there so
we then changed what was originally an
english language only platform into a
multi-language platform so that was the
third major thing that got me involved
and since i started with link i got you
know i've learned
seven languages like i have learned more
languages in the last 10 years than at
any similar period in the past
you know the slavic language is korean
romanian and stuff
and
just talk about a little about the
future yes what kind of projects do you
work on and in your future what kind of
project
are you planning uh english i mean
language wise and even in general
well
because i'm very interested you ask this
question about whether languages are
going to you know become less important
and i think that uh you know we want to
contribute
to making language learning easier and
also possibly to
preserving
uh
some of the minority languages i mean
hungarian is a minority language but
it's in no danger but the languages the
native languages in canada are
definitely in danger and what tends to
happen is let's say with regard to a
minority language
then okay we're going to save cree which
is probably the largest native language
in canada so pretty soon you have
consultants and people wanting to get
government money to write grammar books
and pretty soon they spent millions of
dollars and the number of speakers of a
creed just declines year after year
after year no matter all it does you
create this industry of people who are
going to save cree but in fact you don't
say a creep and what
i'm of the belief that all that is
needed to save a language or to help to
learn a language is the language you
need to get people to talk in the
language you need to describe it you
build up the kind of library that we
have at link with audio and text
and you give people a way of learning
from that material so
even now like for example i think that
i'm studying korean i think
the material that i would like in korean
isn't there there's some very difficult
podcasts that i've had to pay to
transcribe there's some very childish
call it beginner material but there's
not the in-between material
there are people doing this kind of
thing there's a person
when i started polish
pyotr from poland who's building
wonderful material i would like to get
get together with all the people who are
creating interesting content
not only in sort of english french
chinese which are the or arabic or
whatever that are the most popular
languages but potentially in all of them
hungarian let's get some content you
know and that's where i fight with mark
because i would like to have more
languages at link and he
from a practical point of view he can't
justify it because we don't have enough
people who would learn hungarian and
even you know i managed to get ukrainian
put in there but i wouldn't say i'm the
only one but i'm one of the few people
studying ukrainian so those are the
kinds of things related to language
people getting together understanding
each other being able to access each
other's culture that kind of thing
what makes you keep learning ah learn a
new language
okay
all right very good question so
you know initially i
learned french
and i just got turned on i got turned on
to french culture
in those days french movies
french
literature things french and as a result
i then went to france and i studied in
france for three years
uh chinese i then i started working for
the canadian government
and the canadian government was about to
recognize the people's republic of china
and so they needed to train up people
who could speak chinese so when i heard
about this i thought i thought that
would be fun i would like to learn
chinese so i actually started learning
on my own
so then i went to the director of
personnel
and i said i hear you're looking for
someone to learn chinese you should
choose me because i've already started
on my own
so from their point of view
because
they send someone off to learn chinese
that person may or may not be successful
right so if someone is already motivated
enough to start on their own
then that made their decision easier
right
so so then and of course i studied i
learned chinese and then i went and
lived in japan so
naturally i'm going to learn japanese if
i live in japan i can learn japanese
because
i have the confidence that i can learn
a lot of foreigners live in japan and
don't learn japanese because they think
it's too difficult and so forth so but
by that time i think as you learn
languages you learn one and the second
and the third you just have that
confidence that you can learn
and so then i got just more and more
interested so i learned japanese and
then i learned german and spanish and so
forth so it's just one thing hey
you know in anything in life if you are
successful you want to do it again right
that's i think the brain
if the brain achieves success in
something
that makes the brain happy so it wants
to do more of the same right
and if you don't have success then you
don't want to do it last question is um
do you have any words for people in
their 20s
yeah
first of all i'd step back to the
previous goal i do believe that link
helps people learn languages yeah so
that gives me a great sense of
satisfaction so not only doing it for
myself and i'm a big link user and learn
a lot of languages but it helps a lot of
other people so that makes me feel
better for people in their 20s
if i think back to when i was in my 20s
you can do a lot more than you think you
can
and so people in their 20s should reach
higher
you shouldn't uh don't look at this
don't look at yourself in the mirror so
much
should i do that should i do this this
is no good i'm no good there's a we have
a lot of hesitation when we are younger
and when we get older we realize that
very often we should have gone for more
and we didn't because we weren't sure
and we didn't feel confident and and and
as you get older then
you there's less of those kinds of
moments of doubt but my advice to
younger people is boy you can you can do
a lot more than you think you can try to
rise and like grammar don't
no no
every time i look at the grammar rules i
think i'm learning something but in fact
i'm not yeah
i'm not because
next time i still get it wrong let's put
it this way if you have already noticed
something in the language
and then you see a grammar rule that
explains it
they say oh okay so now it explains
something that you already know
but if you don't have any experience
with this
then the grammar explanation is just a
waste of time
and there's complicated terms and
exceptions and and stuff and i just i
stay away from it best grammar book is
the smallest grammar
very small grammar book with a few rules
and then examples examples are good so i
can look at examples
because
the grammar explanation has to have some
relationship to reality
so to that extent those
examples are good but the exercises i
don't like